bien sûr je suis confiant s'il était pas
confiance je rester tranquillement chez
moi je crois ce que je fais je me sens
portée par une adhésion qui rêve alain
juppé avec 36% des intentions de vote -
6 points devance toujours nicolas
sarkozy à 30% mais la dynamique est du
côté de françois fillon +7 points en moi
18% pouvait analyser la situation
d'abord je pense que françois fillon
était sans doute sous-estimé dans les
sondages précédents
le duo a annoncé par les médias et mars
à l'arrière on a vendu survendu un duel
pendant des mois
aujourd'hui c'est un trio on est à une
semaine du premier tour on verra bien
qui sera le duel de deuxième tour
c'est un revenu véritablement universel
est ce que tout le monde va nous toucher
de madame bettencourt je ne veux pas tu
as créé naturellement jusqu'à la
vendeuse de prêt zune et votent pas
juppé pour éviter sarkozy ou sarkozy
pour éviter juppé en votre fille ont
pardonné dans mon quartier et vous
demanderez aux gens s'ils me vois
souvent non pas au prisunic montagne je
bats ma coulpe
j'ai envie c'est lamentable ça
disqualifie ma candidature à la
présidence de la république je le
reconnai volontier daniel tram a dit
hier soir aux manifestants dans son pays
n'ayez pas peur nous allons retrouver
notre pays
j'aimais vraiment n'ayez pas peur
l'élection vient d'avoir lieu
seul vrai et il faut nous donner du
temps à des coupeurs de donald est la
seule fois scandale aussi en une du
journal métro qui parle d' insulte à la
mémoire de ceux qui ont combattu le
nazisme
je traduis métro on donne du temps
d'antenne leader fasciste en ce jour du
souvenir leader fasciste c'est comme ça
que le journal voit marine le pen
méritoire de donald trump est une pierre
en réalité supplémentaires dans
l'émergence d'un nouveau monde qui a
vocation à remplacer un ordre ancien
para côté promesses donald trump a
confirmé qu'il nommerait à la cour
suprême des juges anti avortement est
favorable au port d'armes à feu
en revanche il ne va pas remettre en
cause le mariage homosexuel ce que nous
allons faire c'est prendre les gens qui
sont des criminels et qui ont des
casiers judiciaires qui appartiennent à
des gangs qui sont des trafiquants de
drogue sans doute 2 millions ça peut
aussi être trois millions de personnes
nous allons leur faire quitter le pays
où nous allons les mettre en prison
vraiment construire ce mur oui certains
députés républicains ont dit qu'il
pourrait s'agir une barrière vous
accepteriez barrières pour certaines
zones on pourrait mettre une clôture
mais pour d'autres un mur serait plus
approprié je suis vraiment bon pour tout
ça ça s'appelle la construction il
renonce à son salaire de président
quelques 400 mille dollars annuels
donald trump dont la fortune personnelle
est estimée à 3,7 milliards de dollars
ne percevra que le dollar symbolique
exigé par la loi